um so should linguist correct or
criticize how people talk
should they no but it's fun my name is
Marie schellenberg I work in the
interdisciplinary speech research lab
into the linguistics department at UBC
and I do research there and I teach some
phonetics courses actually when I first
went to university I needed a minor I
was gonna major in music and I needed a
minor and I was flipping through the
catalogue this is back in the days when
the catalogues were still in books and I
was flipping through the catalogue going
I need a minor
I need a minor linguistics yeah that
sounds interesting and I put it down as
my minor by the end of my first year I
liked it so much I had it became my
major but yeah it was a pure fluke that
I ended up in linguistics well so I have
always done music and linguistics I
ended up majoring in linguistics and
minoring in music and because those have
always been my interests I've just
always tried to find a way to mash the
two together and I've just been really
lucky that that's been what I've been
able to do it's fun because I get to
talk to two completely in many ways
unrelated disciplines and I have to be
able to explain linguistics to music and
music to linguists which forces me also
to be really clear about what I'm doing
which is good for me I became a
professor because I really enjoyed the
teaching the research is fun but the
teaching is such a great aspect of it I
love being in the classroom and the
interaction with the students that's a
really important part of the job for me
you